ncap's latest update for Mac ignites the
power of Apple silicon proving it isn't
just for hipsters and YouTubers anymore
this update isn't just a Sprinkle of
pixie dust it's a full-blown workflow
Revolution that will have you pumping
out photo realistic renders faster than
the first comment down below this update
isn't just about speed though andscape
has finally heard our cries and packed
in a ton of features we've been begging
for including improved image capture
meaning your renders just got a hell of
a lot better and you didn't have to do a
single thing how's that for subscribe
worthy they've also added a material
library on absolute massive steroids
this update is more than a game changer
it's a paradigm shift and if you're
ready to see it in action we're about to
press play all right so as you can see
we have arcad 27 open on the one side of
the screen and also nscap on the other
this is the brand new update for
andscape so we're going to be sharing
some incredible new features first of
all let's jump across to Arad and load
up the materials Library the nscap
materials library is filled with so many
goodies and I'm so thankful that they
finally added this in to ncape for Mac
because it was desperately missing from
the last version so as you can see we
have bricks we have concrete Fabrics
glass everything glass is one of my most
impressive features ever to be added in
to andscape or any rendering software
because glass you can just never get
right so by having a series of available
options for us here to use it makes life
just that little bit easier and our
renders just that little bit better same
if we were go to our wood we'd have some
incredible selections of wood that we
wouldn't have previously available to us
so potentially we might be looking at
something like this wood 02 in the
Chevron pattern for our interior renders
or we might be using these wood planks
on the exterior so let's say we want to
import this one here let's import that
selection which means now let's select
this wood over here open up a material
library in aryad and search for wood
you'll see wood 09 planks we press okay
now it's automatically changed that on
our inscape file as well as our Arab
file so that it is updated now obviously
it is the wrong way around so we have to
adjust that in Ary cab manually because
it is imported as it's own texture into
Arad perfectly so if we simply open up
our surfaces rotate at 90° you'll see it
perfectly lines and in endcap if we fly
in now it's also beautiful texture where
we wanted it to be they've also improved
their material editor library so let's
load that wood 09 we have all of the
individual items there as before let's
say we want to make it Pink maybe we
want to make it black tying it in and
finishing it off super quickly without
ever having to affect the actual aryad
model itself and if we go across look at
that texture it is incredibly well
detailed especially compared to that
original texture I used and imported
directly from articad itself so here
down the middle you can see a vast
difference in quality in material and
depth which is only ever going to make a
render so much better now that quickly
covers our new material Library which is
incredible it is definitely one of my
favorite things in this entire update
but what we also have is batch rendering
so let's say you've created a series of
screenshots you've got your drone front
your Front
Street and potentially your left view
previously you would have had to export
them one by one now we have fantastic
batch export so instead of hitting the
individual screenshot export you can hit
batch rendering select all three and
then hit render images in that instance
it'll export all of your images and
you'll be able to view them as batch
exported renders now this render from
the front I haven't touched the only
thing I've changed in this latest update
is the timber cladding right here in the
sunlight ncape claims that this update
will significantly improve your image
capture without you having to do a
single thing so what I'm about to do is
leave this image and place the original
image I exported from the previous
version of ncape and place them side by
side for a direct comparison now to be
fair I did move the yellow car across
and take out this gray car from these
renders but without changing a single
thing you can see there are vast
improvements to these renders first of
all if we take a look at the lights and
shadows on the actual concrete itself
the newest render being on the right
hand side here and the old render being
on the leftand side for those that weren
paying attention you going to see the
concrete the lights and the Shadows is
significantly improved we don't have
that blown out image as we previously
did we also have a lot more texture and
depth in the trees in the foreground and
the background and our characters have a
little bit of more warmth to the overall
scene now I haven't changed any of these
settings it was a direct open of both
systems to export these images overall I
definitely think it has improved I think
they have made a phenomenal enhancement
from just a minor update which is
actually proving to be quite a major one
what we didn't previously have in the
last version of nscap which was a huge
surprise to me as well was video editing
capabilities so now we actually have the
ability to export videos in andscape not
just Ste images as we did before so if
we were to create one key frame here
start by swinging around to the front of
the property showing the absolute front
beautiful facade that we've created hit
the plus again and then finally swing
around to the other side of this house
hit our final plus button
and press the play we'll see a beautiful
slow transition from the front to the
back and it will create a very nice
video obviously we can do so much more
with this we can ease in and out we can
have a shaky camera if we're trying to
create movement but overall we now have
video in our endcap what I do want to
see and what is critical is the export
quality of this video so I'm going to
hit the export button and see you guys
in a minute okay so that took about 15
minutes to export that entire my video
and personally I would have loved to see
a countdown timer saying 10 minutes 5
minutes 3 minutes left instead of a
percentage bar but that's okay now this
is going to be the first time we both
watch the first export from the brand
new andscape update together so we have
already in full screen mode Let's press
play overall actually this is quite
impressive you see the trees moving you
see the actual Shadows moving as well 20
seconds overall total scene it's quite
inviting it's quite Pleasant it looks
very very very good I'm impressed with
the Shadows over the texture that we've
placed on this garage I'm overall
impressed with the sky as well and the
highlights and the Shadows personally I
think this is an exceptional render for
something that I took about 5 Seconds to
do it didn't take me very long to export
this whatsoever we'll play it through
once more obviously if I put a bit more
time and effort into this this could be
significantly better but it was just a
first time render to see the quality
overall you can still see even on a Mac
Studio with an ultra M1 chip you still
have a bit of blurring and a bit of
hazing cuz the rate tracing isn't
perfect I'd love to try this with the
new M3 Max chip potentially this would
be even better than what we're seeing
right now and this is exported in Ultra
HD so overall I think it's a fantastic
update with only one last feature that
we haven't talked about now as an Arad
user this doesn't interest me that much
however there are many of you out there
that AR exclusively on archicad this
latest update for andscape also allows
you vray scene export which is in beta
testing and also Rhino 7 support
previously we only had SketchUp vect
works and aryad now we're also blessed
with Rhino 7 if you're new to the
channel let's have a quick little
intrude and get to know each other first
of all my name my name is David tomich
I'm registered architect here in Western
Australia and my goal is to give you as
much architectural content as humanly
possible I want to reveal the industry
secrets that people are not sharing the
things that you do not learn at
University that you do not get taught in
the real world that you just have to
find out through trial and error that's
what this channel is for that's what
we've been doing for the past 4 years
the goal for 2024 is to grow this
channel as much as we possibly can so we
want to take it from about 46,000 where
it stands today all the way up to
100,000 subscribers I'm hoping that
you're going to be able to help us with
that goal by simply smashing the
Subscribe button down below and that's
it that's all we have to do if you're
interested in more of what I do there is
a link down below to my website
david.com.com that can calculate every
dollar from the Builder quote and of
course if you've accelerated your
architectural career you're starting
your own projects there is a full custom
architectural brief available for you to
use with your clients to be able to
pinpoint the exact project the exact
needs of every single person that walks
in your door